the worst violence in years between
israelis and palestinians is
intensifying israel's military attacked
new targets in gaza
the palestinian territory where
militants are firing hundreds of rockets
into israel
and in the israeli-occupied west bank
palestinian protesters fought with
police
mts tayab is outside tel aviv where the
violence
is taking an unexpected turn mts good
morning
hey good morning you know i've been
covering the israeli israeli-palestinian
conflict for
a very long time and the violence that
we saw here in baiyan in which you can
see arab-owned businesses just smashed
to pieces
is something we haven't seen in decades
and the concern now is that this could
spill
into something far more serious
israeli media are calling this a
lynching
after an arab israeli man was pulled
from his car in a tel aviv suburb
and is beaten unconscious by dozens of
far right jewish israelis
the brutal attack was broadcast on live
tv and has been condemned by prime
minister benjamin netanyahu
and the country's chief rabbi when it
comes to scenes like we saw last night
people being attacked businesses being
destroyed have we crossed the line
i think this is different from anything
i've seen and i've been living here for
24 years
i just want to point out that we're all
israelis so jews arabs
we're all israeli a horrifyingly similar
scene was posted on social media from
aker in northern israel
showing a jewish israeli man allegedly
being attacked by a group of young
palestinian arabs
the violence sweeping across towns and
cities with mixed populations of jews
and arabs has been shocking
people homes businesses and places of
worship have all been targeted
this rabbi calls the situation a
nightmare
a nightmare felt acutely in gaza where
israeli airstrikes continue to pummel
the densely populated palestinian
territory
wreaking havoc while hamas continues to
fire rockets into israel
with over 1 000 last night alone since
monday
over 80 palestinians have been killed
and seven israelis in this tit-for-tat
war
but it's the widespread civil unrest in
israel that has leaders across the
region now fearing the decades-old
israeli-palestinian conflict
was now heading into a new deeply
dangerous territory
now the one place that is mercifully
calm this morning is the al-aqsa mosque
in east jerusalem
where really this latest round of
violence all started
and as muslims celebrate the end of the
month of ramadan which is normally
a joyous time really in this moment that
joy
is on edge mts tayyip in israel thank
you very much